>> Tucker: THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE THREATENED 23 SANCTUARY
CITIES, COUNTIES, AND STATES
WITH SUBPOENAS IF THEY DON'T
TURN OVER CERTAIN RECORDS.
IN RESPONSE, NEW YORK MAYOR BILL
DeFAZIO AND SEVERAL OTHER CITY
LEADERS BOYCOTTED THE SCHEDULED
MEETING WITH THE PRESIDENT OF
THE WHITE HOUSE -- AT THE
WHITE HOUSE TODAY.
A FORMER MEMBER OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO BUILDER
SUPERVISORS JOINS US TODAY.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I AM HERE AS DEPUTY COUNTY
EXECUTIVE FOR THE COUNTY OF
BECAUSE YOU HAVE THAT OFFICIAL
ROLE IN CALIFORNIA, LET ME ASK
YOU THIS.
YOUR ATTORNEY GENERAL, ANNOUNCED
THAT EMPLOYERS IN THE STATE TO
COOPERATE WITH FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION AUTHORITIES WILL BE
PROSECUTED BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHICH, APPARENTLY,
NOW ITS OWN COUNTRY.
WILL YOU PARTICIPATE IN THIS?
U.S. GOVERNMENT ON IMMIGRATION
LAW, WILL YOU TURN THEM INTO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR
PROSECUTION?
>> I THINK I'M GOOD ENOUGH A
LAYER TO KNOW THAT BEFORE I
ANSWER THAT, I WOULD HAVE TO
THE COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA, WE
ARE PROUD TO CALL OURSELVES A
CONSTITUTIONAL COUNTY THAT IS
GOING TO FOLLOW THE LETTER AND
THE SPIRIT OF THE U.S.
CONSTITUTION, AND THAT IS WHY
WHEN IT COMES TO IMMIGRATION
THAT WE ARE VERY CLEAR THAT WE
ARE HERE TO DO THE JOB THAT IS
OUTLINED FOR US BY THE U.S.
CONSTITUTION.
WE ACTUALLY HAVE SUED THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION TWICE AND
IN THE BUSINESS OF ENFORCING
IMMIGRATION LAW     LAW AND, WIT
IMMIGRATION LAW     LAW AND, WIH
IMMIGRATION LAW     LAW AND, WIA
IMMIGRATION LAW     LAW AND, WIL
DUE RESPECT, WE BELIEVE THERE IS
A ROLE FOR THE FEDERAL
SANTA CLARA --
>> Tucker: SINCE YOU ARE A
LAWYER WHO HELPS RUN A
BIG COUNTY AND THE BIGGEST
STATE, ANSWER THIS.
IS IT CONSISTENT WITH READINGS
OF THE CONSTITUTION RATIFIED BY
THE SUPREME COURT THAT A STATE
WOULD ACTIVELY WORK TO UNDERMINE
FEDERAL LAW?
I'LL ANSWER FOR YOU.
NO, ACTUALLY.
NO.
THAT HAS NOT HAPPENED SINCE THE
CIVIL WAR.
SO WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON THAT AS
A COUNTY OFFICIAL AND A LAWYER?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, I DON'T THINK
THAT I SHOULD BE IN THE BUSINESS
OF TELLING THE STATE OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HOW TO DO THE
JOB.
LIKEWISE, I DON'T THINK THEY
SHOULD TELL US HOW TO DO OUR
JOB.
I HAVE IN ORDER HERE THAT WAS
ISSUED IN THE NORTHERN DISTRICT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN HIS
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT, SIR, YOU CANNOT
FORCE COUNTIES LIKE SANTA CLARA
TO DO THEIR JOB.
THAT IS NOT YOUR ROLE.
>> Tucker: WE ARE ARGUING
PARALLEL CONVERSATIONS.
I'M NOT ASKING, DO YOUR DUTY TO
DO YOUR JOB.
I'M ASKING YOU WHETHER YOU ARE
ALLOWED, AS AN OFFICIAL OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA, TO ACTIVELY
UNDERMINE FEDERAL LAW AND
PROSECUTE CALIFORNIANS WHO
FOLLOW IT.
REALLY SIMPLE.
AND YOU KNOW, BECAUSE YOU ARE AN
ATTORNEY, I AM ASKING YOU, WOULD
YOU DO THAT IF YOU ARE ORDERED
BY THE ATTORNEY GENERAL ADDRESS
STATE TO HELP PROSECUTE SOMEBODY
OR AID IN THE PROSECUTION OF A
CALIFORNIA CITIZEN, BECAUSE HE
FOLLOWED FEDERAL LAW, WOULD YOU
PARTICIPATE IN THAT?
PROGRAM --
>> Tucker: YES, YOU DO.
YOU ARE A STATE OFFICIAL.
THIS IS SOMETHING YOU SHOULD
THINK ABOUT, BECAUSE WE ARE
MOVING TOWARDS A CONSTITUTIONAL
CRISIS REALLY FAST, AS YOU KNOW,
AS A LAWYER.
IMMIGRANTS, ILLEGAL ALIENS,
WHATEVER, PEOPLE WHO AREN'T
SUPPOSED TO BE HERE, IN
YOUR COUNTY IS A GOOD THING.
HAVE YOU DONE ECONOMIC IMPACT
STUDY ON THAT AND
SANTA CLARA COUNTY?
>> LET ME TELL YOU, MR. CARLSON,
AND I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY, IT IS A PERSONAL
ISSUE FOR ME.
MY PARENTS BROUGHT ME HERE
UNDOCUMENTED AS A CHILD.
I WAS 14.
AND WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS THAT,
WHEN I CAME HERE, IT WASN'T MY
CHOICE, BUT I MADE A POINT OF
>> Tucker: I DON'T WANT TO BE
RUDE.
I THINK YOU HAVE DONE GREAT.
I THINK THAT'S GREAT.
I'M NOT ATTACKING YOU
PERSONALLY.
THERE ARE A LOT OF IMMIGRANTS
LIKE YOU WHO ARE IMPRESSIVE.
BUT THERE ARE ALSO 330 MILLION
AMERICANS WHO ARE ALREADY
HAVE ON THEM.
IF YOU STUDY THE EFFECT OF
IMMIGRATION ON YOUR COUNTY, AND
IF YOU HAVEN'T, AND I KNOW YOU
HAVEN'T, I WANTED TO TELL ME WHY
YOU HAVEN'T.
>> WE BELIEVE THAT THE
IMMIGRANTS THAT ARE PART OF OUR
COUNTY ARE AN ASSET TO OUR
COUNTY.
>> Tucker: BUT DO YOU KNOW
THAT?
HAVE YOU STUDIED THAT?
WHAT WOULD YOU STUDY THAT?
RATHER THAN JUST GAS?
-- GUESS?
>> IF YOU LOOK AT THE
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT IMMIGRANTS
>> Tucker: IT LOOKS LIKE IT --
>> STATUS HAVE BEEN MADE FOR
JURISDICTIONS, FORCING
IMMIGRATION LAW, ACTUALLY SAFER,
AND WE ARE --
>> Tucker: YOU DON'T WANT TO
KNOW.
>> Tucker: I COULD DO WITH A
LITTLE LESS MORALIZING AND A
LITTLE MORE CARE TO THE EFFECT
OF THESE POLICIES ON ACTUAL